not gonna lie regardless of what the
thumbnail looks like in this video i'm
just gonna power through this because i
don't feel very well right now but this
is the movie we're talking about so
let's do it as quickly as humanly
possible
so last night in soho is directed by
edgar wright which right there right out
the gate very intriguing i'm an edgar
wright fan and if for nothing else you
know one of his movies aren't going to
be cookie cutter or conventional the
movie actually stars thomas and mckenzie
i know it'd be easy to say on your
taylor joy right because it doesn't
though anya taylor joy is a supporting
character or for nothing else she's the
focus of the movie but not the eyes of
the audience thomas and mackenzie's
character she she plays an up
up-and-coming and aspiring fashion
designer she's a student to be so she
moves to london the big city you know
very exciting right well she's not
really fitting in so much you know she's
very old-fashioned she she's enamored by
the culture and the music of mid-century
which
they did do music better back then also
she sees dead people listen it's kind of
briefly touched on but
that ability that gift gets its next
phase of pokemon evolution when she
moves to london and when she goes to
sleep she sees and experiences the life
of any taylor joy's character who was an
aspiring entertainer of the mid-century
and then things get really dark for anya
taylor joy's character so like i said
not conventional or cookie cutter but
very edgar wright does horror which is a
thing i'd love about this movie it's it
is it horror it has horror elements it's
one of these movies it's the reason i
miss blockbuster because on a streaming
service you can put this movie in four
different categories no problem but if
this were the vhs stays in blockbuster
there'd be some poor employee or
blockbuster franchise owners like
where do i put it mystery thriller
horror i don't know i always appreciate
it when a movie makes it difficult to
lock its genre in a box regardless of
whatever genre breaking genre aggregate
it is it's undeniably compelling i say
horror because nothing's more horrifying
than reality it's a very
darkly real story the story of people
who prey on the hopes and dreams of
young women is very boulevard of broken
dreams kind of story whether it's
mid-century london or hollywood
now it's very dark and real [ __ ] also
thomas and mackenzie amazing in the
movie she has to be a person who's sweet
and innocent bold and daring also
horrified when she needs to be but also
needs to be strong enough to get through
this story and find out where it leads
and
and end it also anya taylor joy very
different role for her at first you're
like yeah it's omni taylor joy
looking like perfection and you know
performing and makes sense but when
things get darker in her life i guess i
just didn't expect that in the movie the
way it was
way was portrayed but again omni taylor
joy crush is it we would expect no
different also some of the other
standouts in the acting terrence stamps
in the movie a lot of times i feel like
terrence stamp is cast in movies because
he's terrance stamp he's kind of like
christopher walken at this point like
all he has to really do is show up but i
thought he did so much more with such
little time he had again great that
edgar wright brought that out where it's
like okay you don't have a lot of screen
time and you are terrence stamp we could
take the easy road but we're gonna try
to do a little more with less you know
and i was impressed with how much
terence stamp brought to the movie and
the late diana rig you might have
remembered her from game of thrones she
was granny tyrell i believe this was her
last performance before she passed away
i was surprised to see her i didn't know
she was in the movie she plays the
landlord of thomas and mckenzie's
character and again she she brings that
energy you saw in game of thrones that
take no nonsense no [ __ ] old lady
she was amazing again not in the movie
much but you definitely remember her
when the movie ends in the end i was
hoping last night in soho was something
i would remember from the 2021 movie
slate and it absolutely is at its
baseline it's a mystery about a girl now
trying to find out what happened to this
girl from 1960s london but in its
execution it's done in such a unique
manner with the main character living
the life of this girl from
60 years past this could have been such
a cookie-cutter movie a movie that might
be going for an oscar or something it
just came across as messy it takes a
true talent to tell a story that's so
big in scope involving two different
lives but not make it feel convoluted
and actually make it visually appealing
it's equal parts magnificent thrilling
horrifying i love me a good mystery
especially a mystery that transcends its
genre and this absolutely did it's
definitely worth watching definitely
worth buying on blu-ray all right so
last night in soho have you seen it what
did you think about it what's your
favorite edgar wright movie she's done a
lot of great ones i think that's a
pretty good question to ask but whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you